knowing yourself
is the beginning of all wisdom
some save as if they should live forever
others spend
as if they would die right away
a friend to all
is a friend to none
it is the mark of an educated mind to be
able to entertain a thought without
accepting it
what is a friend
a single soul dwelling in two bodies
educating the mind without educating the
heart
is no education at all
hope
is a waking dream
to live is to do things
not to acquire them
no great mind has ever existed
without a touch of madness
happiness depends upon ourselves
wishing to be friends is quick work
but friendship is a slow ripening fruit
happiness is the meaning and the purpose
of life
the whole aim and end
of human existence
patience is bitter
but its fruit is sweet
to perceive
is to suffer
those who know
do
those that understand
teach
he who has overcome his fears will truly
be free
the educated differ from the uneducated
as much as the living differ from the
dead
i count him braver who overcomes his
desires than him who conquers his
enemies
for the hardest victory
is over self
poverty is the parents of revolution and
crime
it is not enough to win a war
it is more important to organize the
peace
the antidote for 50 enemies
is one friend
the high-minded man must care more for
the truth
than for what people think
there is only one way to avoid criticism
do nothing
say nothing
and be nothing
learning is not child's play
we cannot learn without pain
without friends
no one would want to live
even if he had all the other goods
dignity does not consist in possessing
honors
but in the consciousness that we deserve
them
where your talents and the needs of the
world cross
there lies your vocation
the secret to humor
is surprise
fear is pain arising from the
anticipation of evil
the only stable state
is the one in which all men are equal
before the law
anyone who has no need of anybody but
himself is either a beast
or a god
he who is to be a good ruler
must have first been ruled
whatever lies within our power to do
lies also within our power not to do
happiness belongs to the self-sufficient
you can't chase after money
you need to go towards them
for two years a person learns to speak
and then for the rest of his life
he learns to be silent
mothers are fonder than fathers of their
children
because they are more certain they are
their own
nothing destroys a person as much as a
prolonged inaction
don't trust a wife who lets herself not
trust you